of trending or if it's just yep Minnie
Mouse are training at number 24. number
24 Minnie Mouse when I seen this this
morning oh there's Disney is doing
something
well they did something
Disney Paris
designed mini mounts and the first pants
suit
that's this this is what they're pissed
off about
this is it this is the [ __ ] picture
that they're [ __ ] furious about this
is the culture War they're gonna stoke
the CRT culture War the CRT voodoo
because they drew her in a pant suit
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
this crazy ass [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
um let's let's go to the um
well here
Leticia has has this here look oh look
there's Minnie and pants somehow not
destroying the fabric of society just
being an adorable cartoon mouse as one
does this is the really weird
weird [ __ ] thing about this too it's
like you know the the m m candy thing
they were assessed about how sexy it was
or it wasn't right like whatever the
[ __ ] that was supposed to be about
and if you go back and listen to the
tape of Tucker Carlson and I said it the
other day he says the word transition
right that's what he said he says
transition
from high heels to tennis shoes as if as
if a [ __ ] woman can't wear tennis
shoes in the first get the [ __ ] out of
here or be sexy in a pair of tennis
shoes I ain't seen plenty of women that
are plenty sexy in a pair of tennis
shoes
he's got his [ __ ] mind all twisted up
that you have to wear sexy heels to be
sexy get out of here
but the problem is the problem is is
that these people they're they're making
this tart cartoon [ __ ] these cartoon
drawings where where they have certain
clothes or certain shoes or they're not
sexy enough or they're too sexy or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they're
doing
the word transition really works its way
in you notice that I mentioned that the
other day on the Decker Carlson tirade
that I went on about him wanting to [ __ ]
the M M's
because it's here here's the deal
if if Tucker Carlson that white fragile
male walked into a bar and saw really
sexy Eminem I mean hot smoking [ __ ]
hot smoke show Eminem [ __ ] high heels
makeup oh my God this Eminem was the M
M's of Eminem's
he hid on her butter drinks flirted with
her finally he was able to take her home
with him and then when he got home he
discovered that she transitioned in the
tennis shoes
and she wasn't she wasn't the sexy
Eminem she was supposed to be you follow
me you follow me there this is about
this is about trans people that's what
it's about it's they're trying to make
this [ __ ] a sexual culture War
with people who don't give a [ __ ]
the majority of Americans don't give a
[ __ ] who other people are [ __ ] as
long as it's consensual
Andrea is here what's up
we're talking about Minnie Mouse
foreign
this is this is what they're trying to
do is trying to place this word
transition and trying to scare their
[ __ ] constituents to think that
somehow Minnie Mouse or or the the
female Eminem as if an Eminem can have a
gender Jesus Christ this is the same
[ __ ] with the Mr Mrs Potato Head that
they lost their minds about
lost their [ __ ] minds
over a potato not having genitalia
potatoes don't have genitalia they don't
have it
it's an inanimate object cartoons I
guess if you draw it that way it can
have genitalia but Minnie Mouse
doesn't have it
Eminems the cartoons did they don't have
genitalia it's not a thing it's not a
thing
[ __ ] morons okay here's the [ __ ]
clip here's the clip of her of Candace
Owens because
um you know the Eminem The Eminem thing
was on Tucker Carlson right now Jesse
Waters has to have Candace Owens on now
this is this is the really [ __ ] crazy
part
if you look at this screenshot here look
at what she's bitching about she's
bitching about this picture we showed
earlier Where Minnie Mouse is in a
purple suit
right she's in a purple suit and why
it's called a pant suit I have no idea
why in the [ __ ] can a woman just wear a
suit a dude just wears a suit when a
dude wears a suit it's not a pants suit
what the [ __ ] why does it have to be a
pant it's a [ __ ] suit she's got a
[ __ ] suit on
but if you look over here at the person
that's gonna [ __ ] about Minnie Mouse
destroying American society the fabric
of American society because she's
wearing a suit
this [ __ ] has got a suit on she's got a
[ __ ] purple suit look at that it's a
[ __ ] purple suit
Am I Wrong Am I [ __ ] wrong here
she's I mean other than the [ __ ] the
the polka dots on the suit she's
basically dressed the same way that
Minnie Mouse is here in the [ __ ]
picture that's drawn
so who's destroying the fabric of
society Candace the [ __ ] out of here
with this fake ass outrage this is the
[ __ ] that they do folks this is how they
beat Democrats right here this is how
they do it
I'm going to take this banner down so
you can see the stupid [ __ ] on the
screen here too
there you go now you can see Minnie
Mouse swaps see that swaps
you got it you see the language they use
it's that transition language
swaps iconic red dress for pantsuit
let's listen to this [ __ ] idiot
I mean look at this is why people don't
take these people seriously
wait wait are you talking about us
because we aren't we aren't concerned
about Minnie Mouse like the liberal woke
mob didn't go down the Disney and like
hey you know what you gotta do
[ __ ] you know what you got to
do you gotta put Minnie Mouse in a pant
suit and if you don't do it now what the
[ __ ] are you talking you are the ones
the reason why I'm talking about this
[ __ ] right now is because your dumb
asses have a problem with Disney drawing
their cartoons in certain clothes
they're taking all of these things that
nobody was offended by yep you're taking
all these things that no one was
offended by it's like they have to get
rid of them and Destroy them and you
want to cancel [ __ ] Disney and Minnie
Mouse because they drew her with a
pantsuit
the [ __ ] projection here is [ __ ]
ridiculous absolutely crazy you can't
even make this [ __ ] up
like literally this would be an SNL skit
if you [ __ ] wrote it out
they are parroting themselves
because they're bored you know they're
absolutely bored they're trying to
destroy Fabrics of our society
pretending that there's issue they're
bored so we who have to respond to your
dumb ass worried and distracting from
Biden having the biggest [ __ ]
economic boom since 1984 because that's
what they're doing here folks they can't
go on Fox News and be like oh my God Joe
Biden had the biggest [ __ ] economy
boom since 1984. it's the best economy
since the Reagan Administration they
can't do that
how in the [ __ ] would they do that they
can't do that they got to find [ __ ] they
gotta [ __ ] find all kinds of [ __ ]
they got to talk about how [ __ ]
Eminems don't have sexy asses anymore
Minnie Mouse she's not wearing a thong
she's putting on granny panties and
wearing a pantsuit what the [ __ ] are you
people talking about that we're obsessed
and we're [ __ ] bored you people are
the ones who are having it on your show
Disney in Paris drew a cartoon that they
own in a pants suit
and you people are so [ __ ] bored that
you're losing your minds on Fox News in
a purple pants suit
[ __ ] me issues so everybody looks over
here look at Minnie Mouse don't look at
inflation Jesse look look at Minnie
Mouse don't look at the fighting economy
please don't look how successful the
Biden economy is don't look how he's
trying to drag us out of a pandemic even
though we're trying to Gaslight people
into not doing what they should do about
the pandemic to keep us to keep us in a
pandemic that way people remain sick in
our health care System remain strained
so we can blame it on Biden we can blame
it on Biden that evil Biden making
Minnie Mouse wear a pants suit that
[ __ ] also he's really sleepy and
he can't get out of bed and he probably
can't even put a sentence together look
at Minnie Mouse the world was going
forward because you've got to run a
pantsuit never mind that you can't get
anything at the grocery store and you
can't buy a piece of bacon unless you've
got 30 in your pocket okay see this is
the other stupid [ __ ] see this is the
other stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that they do
you can't get anything at the grocery
store who in the [ __ ] is going to the
grocery store and there's empty shelves
I haven't been to one [ __ ]
grocery store with empty shelves have
you
and who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] thinks
bacon is 30 dollars a [ __ ] piece of
bacon
who the who someone who doesn't buy
[ __ ] bacon
or who doesn't pay attention to the
grocery bill definitely knows that a
[ __ ] piece of bacon isn't 30 bucks
purple pant suit
Candace Owens your pantsuit is
destroying the fabric of our society
stop it at least we're addressing the
real problem which is Minnie Mouse
that's right I mean
oh oh the Dismount the [ __ ] the
Dismount parody of herself there is
[ __ ] fantastic well let's oh my God
oh my God I want to cut this out I want
to cut this out and put it the music
somebody somebody please out there cut
this out and put it the music no problem
which is Minnie Mouse at least we're
addressing the real problem which is
Minnie Mouse at least we're addressing
the real problem which is many many
positions in your pocket at least we're
addressing the real problem
30 in your pocket at least we're
addressing the real problem which is
Minnie Mouse someone please get that do
you remember
um back in let's see here's 2012
campaign remember this uh President
Barack Obama went to Arizona I believe
and he was having a rally right it was a
political rally he was running for
president of the United States he was
the president of the United States and
he got on stage and he was talking about
roads and bridges and building roads and
bridges and you know everyone's staying
you know everyone's calling him a
socialist and all this [ __ ]
and he was talking about how businesses
need the government to build things like
roads and bridges so that they have an
economy that the businesses can strive
in like the businesses out there Private
Business relies on the government to
create certain types of infrastructure
so that they can rely on that
infrastructure to to to do business so
that we can have a good economy that's
what he was talking about and when he
said it he said
uh roads if you got a business you
didn't build that
but they cut the roads part off right
and they said you got a business you
didn't build that do you remember that
do you remember that do you remember
when they cut that out and I mean they
pounded it they pounded it and they
pounded it and they pound it because
it's [ __ ] line it's [ __ ] stupid
they created all this outrage and
complete National outrage in Republicans
because Barack Obama I mean I had
personal people tell me that he said
this I'm like yeah he did say those
words but you understand that that
that's not those words
out of context sound like you want them
to sound but they really don't mean what
you think they mean like if you went and
watched the whole clip you'd understand
what the [ __ ] he was saying
alls I'm saying alls I'm saying here in
this case we definitely should not clip
out the part this part here we should
definitely not clip this part out
we should definitely not clip this part
out always in your pocket at least we're
addressing the real problem which is
Minnie Mouse at least we're dressing the
real problem men Minnie Mouse that's the
part so someone please don't cut that
part and loop it over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again and make sure that everyone knows
that the real problem that probably
Republicans have and the real issue that
Republicans want to talk about because
it is an issue in this country you know
there's things like decent wages and DEC
making sure you don't go bankrupt
because of Health Care making making
sure that you're healthy in your shape
you have a decent job you know all those
things a decent education having public
education decent public education for
your children all those things roads
Bridges rule high-speed internet all
those things take second back seat to
Minnie Mouse the most important issue in
this country right now as we speak and
Candace Owens you heard her say it right
here you heard her say it your pocket at
least we're addressing the real problem
which is Minnie Mouse at least we're
dressing the real problem Minnie Mouse
[ __ ] idiots
oh
what the hell are we gonna do
with these [ __ ] boneheads it's 19 19
minutes at in the second hour I told you
this thing was going to be I told you I
told you it's gonna be at least 20 or 30
minutes
uh let's see
um
like literally look at these screenshots
from Aaron
War disease social breakdown political
gridlock Minnie Mouse wearing a pant
suit this is it and again you see the
screenshot here look it says swaps
swaps it's that transition language
that's that's why they're trying to tie
these cartoons to to transgender because
it really gets them fired up you
remember the bathroom thing you know oh
they love to have the bathroom fight
again they would love that the bathroom
fight again this year
you know the bat p you know these
[ __ ] weirdos are completely [ __ ]
obsessed with other people's [ __ ]
genitalia in the bathroom I have never
and I don't know about you but I've
never went into a bathroom to go take a
piss or you know number two and was
worried about other people's genitalia
in a bathroom especially in a public
bathroom I want to get in there and get
the [ __ ] out I'm not worried about other
people you [ __ ] weirdos that are
worried about other people's genitalia
in the bathroom you're the [ __ ]
weirdos you're the ones who are weird
because you're [ __ ] worried about
what other people have in their pants
what are you doing go in the bathroom do
your [ __ ] business and get the [ __ ]
out don't what worry about what other
people are having their pants [ __ ]
weirdos but here it is swaps that word
swaps it really is trying to take hold
of that language transition
that's it
um veteran said don't make a joke about
scared of girls [ __ ] being bigger
oh oh
Andrew said the bathroom [ __ ] is Twisted
as [ __ ] yeah it's really [ __ ] weird
it's really [ __ ] weird
that they are so worried about other
people's [ __ ] in a bathroom you [ __ ]
weirdos but this screenshot was put up
by Aaron
um
but again he's saying here
that they're this is what they're
worried about I mean literally they're
they're cheering on a war
you see Joe here says these freaks
really have a hell of a fetish for
[ __ ] cartoon animals
I mean it's something else
it's something else Joe it is something
else well again this isn't about the
cartoon this isn't about the pantsuit
this is about them tying cartoon
characters to cancer culture and
transgender people they want that
[ __ ] social war you can see him
trying to construct this thing right you
remember [ __ ] last year when they
were constructing the CRT thing for the
junction race they were constructing
this whole CRT thing for the for the
California recall and the and the
youngin race this Voodoo it's [ __ ]
Voodoo no one was teaching white white
children to feel guilty they were
teaching them history actually most
these schools were teaching [ __ ]
history so that white people don't feel
guilty like that's literally they
they're don't don't stop teaching my kid
not to feel guilty white people who feel
guilty about history
is your problem that you feel guilty
you're the racist like when I hear
history
and I'm like oh man that's shameful [ __ ]
that we did I don't feel guilty for it I
don't feel guilty if you feel guilty
when you hear history it's probably a
problem you have not a problem that that
black people have black Americans black
people people of color it's probably not
that
that that the critical race theory is is
is got you deluded and that's what this
is this is their new critical rate they
tried this uh you guys remember a couple
I think it was a month ago they tried
this Mass formation psychosis remember
this this [ __ ] doctor this they claim
you've created the vaccine which he did
not that's all a [ __ ] lie he's butt
hurt because millions of these vaccines
are being sold and and none of them none
of them and none of that money is going
to him that's what he's [ __ ] butt
hurt about he went on Joe Rogan's show
and he said uh uh people who are taking
the vaccine and believing about the
vaccine is mass formations zygosis like
it was a total [ __ ] and and and Jack
poziak or whatever the [ __ ] that fascist
name is he's continuing with this Mass
formation psychosis they're trying to
make that the next CRT but Fox News is
all in on the cartoon CRT [ __ ] the
cartoon trans transphobic
transphobic candy has to be sexy thing
they are terrified these white fragile
males Like Jesse Waters and Tucker
Carlson are terrified that they would
find a woman who used to be a man
attractive they're terrified that that
woman's [ __ ] may be bigger than theirs
Aaron is that good Yoda is that what you
were looking for
all right
Aaron also post this screenshot look at
this Minnie Mouse and Eminem's have
major makeovers they are [ __ ]
obsessed
obsessed with it oh my God they're
obsessed with the email lady like they
can't help but tie it back to email lady
right like wearing pantsuits is bad
okay well here's the thing Candace Owens
when have you ever seen her not in a
pant suit like literally and again it's
a suit it's a suit
I don't know maybe I maybe I'm uh maybe
I'm
um overstepping my bounds there
but it's a [ __ ] shoot when a dude
wears it it's a suit
I don't know maybe I'm Wrong Am I Wrong
I I don't know anything about fashion to
be quite honest with you all right let's
see what else we got
uh and Joe appears in the trendy Trends
all the time Joe's one of our favorite
uh overhead today at school did you see
what they did to Minnie Mouse
the country is falling apart how
terrible what's next I can't even so sad
me it's a cartoon mouse and pants
did you guys even hear yourself
[Laughter]
oh oh
sounds like uh
Joe is having language around her that
they they watch Fox News apparently
people around Joe watch Fox news last
night
and at that oh here we go here's another
one from Joe she's in the trend what am
I gonna do
Joe's one of my favorite accounts and
she's in the trend I gotta I gotta play
It's My Show
pretending to be upset about Minnie
Mouse wearing pants is just plain goofy
happy Thursday all right well I'm going
to admit something here right on the
show since Joe brings it up uh I I do a
decent a decent goofy well hey Minnie
are you wearing a pantsuit I'm just I'm
just saying I'm just saying maybe we
could go someone could do if you want a
voice over for a sketch Gabe if you're
listening out there if you wanna if you
wanna goofy if you want a goofy
uh voice over okay let's let's move on
ah here's another Scary Larry the same
party that insists Democrats can't be
taken seriously is losing its [ __ ] over
green M M's heels and Minnie Mouse pants
suits and never fails
like they always they always pile this
[ __ ] on right you remember you remember
um last year they were on the tirade
about you know potatoes not having
genitalia you remember this [ __ ] the Mr
Potato Head missed Potato Head because
all all Hasbro did was bait these
[ __ ] I think they're like oh
yeah these people are totally gonna
[ __ ] about this they're totally gonna
[ __ ] about about if we change the
[ __ ] gender of the potato right
because it's Mr Potato Head you can't
you can't take away the mister but but I
guess they just changed the box like it
just they took off the mister off the
top of the box and put Potato Head on it
and then and then whether you were
buying the mister or the misses it set
it down at the bottom right so they're
just changing the art
they've lost their [ __ ] minds for
months and then it was the Dr Seuss
thing all at the same time it was Dr
Seuss Potato Head Dr Seuss Potato Head
they can't just have one because it's so
[ __ ] ridiculous they can't just talk
about how they want to [ __ ] M M's or
they don't want to [ __ ] Eminem's anymore
because M M's aren't sexy I guess that's
a narrative you know they're they're
transitioning right they're
transitioning so M M's aren't sexy
anymore because they're transitioning
right
it's a language
but they got to add in many miles so
it's not so ridiculous
[Laughter]
that's right here says if Republicans
Republicans have been imagining having
sex with Minnie Mouse all this time
couldn't they just imagine her without
pants
yeah that is true that's that's the
other weird [ __ ] thing here right
shine makes a good point
I've never looked at Minnie Mouse and
like ooh sexy sexy Minnie Mouse like I
didn't think Disney never really I don't
think they were drawing Minnie Mouse to
be sexy do you I mean my assumption was
is like Minnie Mouse was a young girl
right like a young adult woman like
she's not she could possibly be a
teenager even possibly in some of those
cartoons some of the situations right
yeah I don't know I'm just saying it's a
little on brand it's a little on brand
for these Republicans to be spotting out
that Minnie Mouse is dressed a certain
way and she may look a certain age I
don't know scenes on brand to me with
all this [ __ ] Matt get [ __ ] running
around maybe they should venmo an artist
to draw up Minnie Mouse in a sexy
situation get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
okay let's see here that that damn
um
worth 29 minutes 30 minutes into the
hour see I told you we're going to do 30
minutes on Minnie Mouse I told you it
was gonna be 30 minutes
now here's another clip what is this
this seems like a longer clip
it is a longer clip this is the lead up
oh I'm very interested in this let's go
watch this let's see what this is I have
some real news and I can't believe I'm
actually saying this Candace but Disney
I have some real news
this
real really this is it
they really are a [ __ ] parody look we
have here on the Tony Michaels podcast
we have a parody News Network it's
called really news now I'm not [ __ ]
you we got a [ __ ] we got a [ __ ]
Twitter account we've done a couple
videos
uh the one show in particular speaking
of Joe Becky Sue was on you know the
character that Joe does Becky Sue
MJ says Candace sucks well
her pantsuit sucks here it's destroying
the fabric of society
she's wearing a [ __ ] pant suit she's
wearing a suit she's wearing a suit
she couldn't just take oh my God
I forgot where I was at thanks MJ
let's just watch the [ __ ] video
is totally changing Minnie Mouse Disney
is putting Minnie Mouse in a pantsuit
that's right they're getting rid of this
okay okay there there is no indication
that that Disney is changing Minnie
Mouse these people
oh you give them [ __ ] one goddamn
millimeter one one goddamn millimeter
just one
just one oh Andrea did she pointed out
what where I was at a parody news that's
it that's it see that's what I was
talking about before MJ distracted me
saying Candace sucks thank you Andrea
we'll get back to that
these people are believing they take
they you give them a little bitty
[ __ ] nugget where this is one picture
just one [ __ ] drawing of Minnie Mouse
in a pantsuit
just one and all of a sudden Disney's
changed the whole [ __ ] character made
her into a dude whatever they think
whatever the hell they're gonna say
whatever the hell they want to do right
because it's this swap transition talk
that they're folk they can't stop
focusing on other people's [ __ ] sex
lives like they just can't stop
but Jesse Waters thinks this is real
news
that Disney has completely changed the
character which they did not this is
really [ __ ] dumb so back to the the
parody news account we actually have
parody news count if you go check it out
it's really news now you can just you
you can search it here I'll um
I believe it's uh
I can't remember the [ __ ] handle
right now
it's really yeah it's really newsing out
here I'll type it down
really news now
on Twitter
there's the there's the handle really
news now on Twitter
if you go over there and there's a there
might be a video
of Carl or Carl tuckerson
show White Privilege tonight it's over
there I'm just saying if you want to go
watch it skirt
and this is Disney Paris or something
like that and I thought who better to
ask about this than Candace Owens you
react who better to ask about this than
about a mini being drawn in a purple
pants suit than the person who appears
on my show about with a purple pantsuit
what the [ __ ]
why are they doing this oh I'm just so
glad I'm so glad they're doing this let
me just tell you Jesse it goes back to
like when they did this the M M's and
now they're making her more masculine
and I'm glad that they're now saying
realizing that this needed to be
addressed you know all of us were trauma
MJ MJ I wasn't tossing on the bus I'm
saying what I'm saying is you distracted
me with the comment Candace sucks and
the reason why is because I had another
15 minutes to do just on that comment
but I can't do it here on YouTube I
can't do that kind of content here on
YouTube thank you MJ
hypnotized when we saw Minnie Mouse and
and she was looking like a female as we
were growing up I mean look if this is
why people don't take these people
seriously they're taking all of these
things that nobody was offended by it's
like they have to get rid of them and
Destroy them because they're bored you
know they're absolutely important
again saying that there's issues so
everybody looks over here look at Minnie
Mouse don't look at inflation Jesse look
at Minnie Mouse where the world is going
forward because you've got her in a
pantsuit never mind that you can't get
anything at the grocery store and you
can't buy a piece of bacon unless you've
got thirty dollars in your pocket at
least we're addressing the real problem
which is Minnie Mouse we're addressing
the real problem which is Minnie Mouse
someone please cut that [ __ ]
please please and put it on a loop to
some music or some [ __ ] I'm telling you
it'd be gold Tick Tock gold over there
okay let's see what else do we have we
are 35 minutes see I told you we did 30
minutes on a mini oh oh here you go here
you go
Minnie Mouse is turning on Twitter
because she's wearing a pantsuit as part
of Disney paris's promotion and the news
of overreacting and acting like she
ain't gonna wear or dress no more Bruh
Bruh this literally ain't the first time
she looks looks good really good in pant
suit look at this okay there's that one
uh there's that one
it's not even a drawing they [ __ ]
made the pantsuit for her they made the
[ __ ] suit for her right they didn't
just draw it they [ __ ] made it and
Minnie Mouse still appears in the dress
you people really are [ __ ] boneheads
you really are [ __ ] boneheads
uh you know we we looks like Matt Getz
is going to be the dishonorable mention
of the week for bonehead of the week
tomorrow but oh [ __ ]
uh here's another one so Minnie Mouse
and pants
like here it is like there's there she
is in pants again
and really honestly this drawing is a
hell of a lot more salacious than than
most drawings of many
Jesus Christ
it's Minnie Mouse people it's [ __ ]
Minnie Mouse let's see if we can find
some more drawings of Minnie Mouse and
pantsuits oh oh here you go
Alex says so it's okay for Canada songs
to wear fancies but not Minnie Mouse
come on Candace what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] and it's not even a good
pantsuit at least they drew many in a
fashionable pantsuit
jeez let's see I did do
there's a clip again let's see if
there's any more pictures
oh here you go here you go hey here's
some more pictures if you're a fan that
is really deep into franchise you would
probably know that Minnie Mouse is is
fashion is fashion versatile like
literally they put her in all kinds of
clothes here's the overalls like I was
saying earlier overalls [ __ ]
gardening hat and this looks like some
sort of superhero suit
look it's a cartoon you [ __ ] idiots
they're gonna draw her in all kinds of
costumes it's a [ __ ] cartoon
damn
uh here you go here's some more pictures
of Minnie Mouse
pants dresses all kinds of [ __ ] right I
can't believe I'm jumping into this but
Minnie Mouse has several different
costumes at every Park conservatives are
raging truly breaking news alert raging
because she got one more and it doesn't
require a bloomer because that's the
thing she wears Bloomers what about what
about Donald Duck Donald Duck doesn't
even wear [ __ ] pants how do these how
does canasons feel about Donald Duck
not wearing pants that motherfucker's
running around with his duck dicks
hanging out right she offended by that
huh maybe Donald Duck should put pants
on is that what she's gonna advocate for
Disney needs to put pants on that
goddamn duck Jesus Christ a duck running
around slinging that duck dick
everywhere I mean uh we gonna do that is
that what we're gonna do Jesus Christ
yeah Winnie the Pooh yeah Andrew Winnie
the Pooh does not does not [ __ ] does
not [ __ ] wear pants either
Yoda says do not give them new ideas no
I I would love to clown them if they
were talking about duck dick come on
Donald Duck dick if they if they went on
Fox News Jesse Waters or Tucker Carlson
was talking about Donald Duck dick you
don't think I can make [ __ ] 30
minutes out of that [ __ ]
oh let's see what else we got here
when a sparker say also the Minnie Mouse
story is even dumber than it being made
out to be on Fox it's not even a
permanent change just a one-off costume
change for a single event
yeah well let's see originally uh her
original tweet rather than write a whole
new one of these just find replacement
green M M's with Minnie Mouse that's
right
they just rage like the last person
saying just rage about anything and just
copy paste right copy [ __ ] paste
and again it's the whole transition swap
chicks with dicks [ __ ] language
that's what they're doing that's the
language that they're using
oh you know they're making into this
whole [ __ ] sexual thing
Tucker Carlson acts like he beats off
the M M's and [ __ ]
okay let's see here
uh here you go there you go
oh yeah oh so Candace Owens is so woke
about Minnie Mouse wearing a pant suit
again
I guess rats with pants suits feel
threatened oh [ __ ]
uh for you guys watch are listening on
the podcast this is Candace Owens
wearing a pantsuit standing next to
Donald Trump with this stupid [ __ ]
thumbs up I don't know why did you do
that thumbs up like Thumb in the butt
thing I don't know why he does a thumbs
up thing it's like a reaction or
something so Candace Owens is woke up I
guess rats
oh [ __ ] God damn people with the [ __ ]
Minnie Mouse jokes
thank you so much
it's a good Thursday oh let's see what
else we got here
of course there's hundreds and hundreds
of pictures of Minnie Mouse and [ __ ]
in [ __ ] pants like you just rolled
down this thread and there they are
pants pants pants she's in pants oh
there she's in pants oh there she's in
another costume oh look that's a
different costume oh look they drew in
something different here oh look there's
she is in pants oh she looks completely
different in that drawing oh there's
some pants
it really is [ __ ] dumb
it really is [ __ ] dumb I I'm not sure
what's [ __ ] more moronic
this [ __ ] Minnie Mouse can't wear
pants or or Tucker Carlson wants to have
sex with M M's it really is [ __ ]
weird okay let's see what else we're 40
minutes into the hour the second hour of
the shitless Roundup
let's take a quick break
and we'll be right back after these
messages
[Music]
you sit your ass down sit the flip now
we're not finished the Tony Michaels
podcast we'll be right back
foreign